depuis le 1er janvier dernier martinique
transport est devenue l'autorité unique
des transports en martinique
ce guichet unique un conseil
d'administration composé de 15 membres
son président alfred marie-jeanne et
dans son procès d'administration neuf
élus de la ccm et deux élus de chaque
communauté d'agglomération martinique
transports devra donc absorber les
compétences transports de la cacem de
cap nord de l'espace sud est de la ctm à
l'exception bien sûr du transport aérien
ce nouvel établissement public devra
donc gérer tous les transports sur notre
territoire de passagers ou de
marchandises transport maritime ou
terrestre
pour l'instant cet organisme n'a pas
d'organigramme il ne dispose pas non
plus de locaux il devra également
embauché les fonctionnaires travaillant
dans les services transport des quatre
collectivités soit un peu moins de 70
personnes
un personnel mobilisé depuis quelques
semaines et qui souhaitent obtenir des
réponses à des questions comme par
exemple leur statut administratif seront
ils mis à disposition en détachement ou
indisponibilité ils n'ont toujours pas
de réponses à leurs questions
dans quelques semaines tout ce personnel
sera très certainement regrouper et dans
quelques jours on devrait connaître le
nom du nouveau directeur général de cet
établissement public